le côté non conformiste du personnage de
vous plaire parce que vous vous êtes un
peu comme cela sans être pour autant
externe irai pas jusqu à la bourre jean
luc hess que pierrot le fou c'est
l'histoire du fait divers c'est
l'histoire de pierre doutre elles n'ont
absolument pas non
c'est l'histoire d'un type il s'appelle
même pack héros s'appelle ferdinand dur
stcc la fille donc il est amoureuse qui
qu'il appelle pierrot pour l'énerver il
lui répète sans arrêt je m'appelle
ferdinand
j'appelais ferdinand souvenir de louis
ferdinand céline karl aventures de
ferdinand est une sorte de voyage au
bout de la nuit et impression ce que
jean paul ii manqué de passer sous un
train abbas à la pression ces images
auraient jamais me suicider en se jetant
sous un train
j'ai apprécié que vous êtes partis au
tout dernier moment couru en chope on va
peut-être aller encore plus prudents
pour à peine de se faire accrocher les
aucune appréhension avant ce genre de
scène ça paraît simple mais c'est tout
même dangereux par l'appréhension non
parce que quand même j'ai des bonnes
jambes chez ces souris et me lever à
temps car il ferait quand on revient que
toi ça te donne le signal pour y aller
c'est que vous êtes en très souvent le
l'agent d'un destin cynique godard oui
mais là je crois que c'est un personnage
qui qui est tous les rôles que j'ai fait
c'est à dire c'est à la fois une femme
est une femme vivre sa vie le petit
soldat ne pensait pas vous êtes là la
femme fatale 1965 finalement moi oui
n'entravera j'aime vivre qu'à n'importe
quoi alors je crois pas que ce soit
tellement fatale je comprends qu'une
tête à ça ailleurs
sait jamais peut-être mais j'aimerais
beaucoup pour moi c'est un film sur la
vie la vie et les les noir et rose ça
dépend comme on l'a regardé ya du soleil
ou six ans il ya des nuages en général
et les deux ensembles passé de
l'histoire de gens qui vont vers le
soleil et puis mais ils doivent
traverser beaucoup de nuages
angué arrivée vous entendez bien avec
jean paul belmondo très bien mais
surtout que ce qui ravi du travail avec
jean-paul parce que j'ai l'impression
que moi j'ai toujours le trac toute
façon alors mais avec jean paul jean
paul i l'allemagne à d'être tu tellement
naturel qu'est ce que j'apprécie le plus
chez lui en dehors de l'acteur bien sûr
je ne connais pas très bien mais enfin
comme
c'est la disponibilité enfin la certaine
forme de gentillesse qui fait qu est
toujours disponible et prêt à partir à
sauter à faire quelque chose enfin joué
à exister c'est une grande qualité trop
comment se fait-il votre avis qu'ils
plaisent tellement aux femmes mais je
pense parce que jean-paul il a du charme
et je crois que c'est ce qu'il ya plus
important nous c'est quand on a du
charme il ya du talent il et j'ai pas il
est pas bon millier pas mal quoi
[Musique]